[Music]
yes why is that out of wait what the
[ __ ] is this ye pity pies oh my god it
keeps going Jesus Christ you guys are
[ __ ] weird let's move on to what I
really want to talk about today
unlicensed PewDiePie merchandise why do
I it plagues the Internet every meet up
I'm a ago - I see I see you wearing the
shirts but I'm like that ain't my shirt
I found the answer
[ __ ] eBay they're everywhere I have
nothing to do with these t-shirts
although they look really cool I like
the style with the with the sleeves is
that it's not like a thing you do now
I guess it's if it's on a pretty pie
shirt it must be cool right you [ __ ]
stole my [ __ ] name and likeness
I've trademark PewDiePie all right I
could sue the [ __ ] out of you ain't no
party like PewDiePie party shirt 43 sold
of these what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
oh oh they're reselling my book they're
reselling my book how dare you and this
is just one of many Oh God Internet
YouTube Xbox Playstation we gamer
inspired t-shirt at least can you make
them decent this one doesn't even say
how many who bought this look at the
eyes there's not this shitty is drawing
I've seen in my life what the [ __ ] there
PewDiePie handbook oh there's only two
available who does
want to spend 52 pounds but I don't know
how much there is pootie pi/6 almost 70
bucks
Julia Priya Beasley what is in it what
is in this book what in what what it
possibly would you need to know about
pretty [ __ ] high videos oh wow
the 27 success facts everything you need
to know about ewdiepie Francie who the
[ __ ] is friends hehehe whatever I think
of puta pie
I think of an apple in front of a book I
I've seen these for sure if you have one
of these in your closet I want you to
take it out put it on the outside put
gasoline on that [ __ ] and burn it and
don't burn yourself and sue me Hey look
at these bit oh look at those Wow I'll
take six okay honest to god if you see
all 25 song if you find one of the 25
people who bought this snapped head and
you happen to have a gun on you please
resist from shooting them in the neck oh
hey oh they they they really stuck with
this one who doesn't want a pencil case
a fantastic gift idea
[Music]
[ __ ] pencil case oh wow look at these
hot guys you can be one of them wearing
a tank tab like look at that look like
the shittiest [ __ ] [ __ ] hey there it
is I actually want one of those oh I can
get a mini one that's pretty cool
who doesn't want a customized PewDiePie
pillow with your name on it I mean I
would love to have one of the set on set
on puta pot you want to set on pour
apply that's a great image
zoella looks fantastic oh my god you can
get a replica play button I'll get one
look at one in blue that's pretty cool
now I can finally replace the shitty one
YouTube's send me that's awesome for
only 65 bucks a Call of Duty
professional slash youtubers signed
hoodie for only 4,000 oh wow who do we
have here of course we have if that came
is that keemstar
that's Jean King star became stars
signed hoodie oh my god take all my
money I'm buying this shirt who doesn't
want that
[Music]
no RedBubble notoriously famous website
for selling a bunch of unlicensed merch
I bought a thing there once and it was
the shittiest quality I couldn't like
not even wire it once but I really
appreciate the fact that if you search
PewDiePie and scroll down this this
picture comes up because I would rather
buy this than any of that other [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey you can get it as a baseball
sleeve that's that I mean that looks
good right then that looks real [ __ ]
nice doesn't it my cig my a driver
license from Gothenburg Sweden got my
birth date and everything I wonder if I
use this one it would work but if this
it's the absolute [ __ ] worst thing I
have ever seen this [ __ ] bro army oh oh
wait a minute this is my merch
if you buy an unlicensed PT primer I
don't really care that much I just think
it sucks because you get such a shitty
product I really want to redo my March I
want it to be something that not just
you would wear but wanna wear and I
don't think that's that is definitely
not the case here I think please if you
want some put paid merch let me know
maybe you don't care I don't care if you
don't care but I want to make something
cool cuz really merch is probably one of
the best thing ways to support wherever
you wash on YouTube and that's it for me
for now don't buy any unlicensed March
even though I said I don't care I do
care please do not I don't want to
[ __ ] see you ironically especially
where it they would like for more likes
and I'll see you bros in the next video
thank you so much for watching and as
always stay awesome no Jimmy no it's the
beads that are smaller pieces
great person oh [ __ ]
the pizza is aggressive oh [ __ ] don't
you just hate when your dad dies from an
aggressive pizza just another day in the
life of Jimmy Neutron